too many emoji guys you are blocking everything how many people connected crazy
let me see from settings can you hear me let me remove this oh oh
now it's amazing
okay let me see the chat how are you guys how are you how many of you saw my content
live trading live charting somewhere while you are here
let me see if i can directly share it seems to work fine seems to work fine it's the first
time for me using this platform but seems to work fine let me see can you see my screen
should be visible
should be visible so i have the chat here i have perfect i have welcome to blood sweat and scalps
amazing amazing let's wait some minutes that everyone connect so just to clarify for everyone
this is not for beginners
point one so if some friends of you told that you should study from me you don't know
anything about trading you don't even know what is a candle this is not for you okay if you are already
studying order flow if you know if you saw at least my video on youtube you know what i'm doing you know
what i explain in terms of order flow even if you don't know my model this is still for you
and if you are in the process of being a break-even trader and wants to get a stable long equity line
this is for you is it clear guys one in chat
amazing we have already 256
what an amazing community then guys also you have to know that at the moment on youtube
on instagram on cumulative audience we have more than 200 000 followers
okay this community aims to be maximum one percent of the total follower okay so
the mission that i'm trying to achieve and the reason i opened this community is because i wanted a
pack of soldiers that are really committed that see trading not only as an hobby but want really to
become killers in this market and i know that out of all these people the people that will really
make it and will make a living out of it and will become professional it's around two three four percent
okay i'm shooting for an even smaller number one percent and my role here is not to be soft with you
my role here is not to tell you what trading is not that it will be easy my role here is
war general okay i will treat you like soldiers i will be rude sometimes with you but i will equip you
with the best mindset model risk management model and trading models that you will ever find on the
internet is it clear guys perfect
perfect loud and clear amazing now let's go on what will blood sweat and scalps be how we will build it
and how this is structure for everyone okay as you saw there is the section battleground
operation okay this section here is the section where you will find all kind of announcement from the team
okay so you will receive information from me about when we go live the topic of the week the menu of the week
what you can expect uh also that section will be used to go through the battleground setup preparation
of the week okay because we will use the profile to understand
who is dominating the volume of the week and of the single session okay so you will receive update on me on
how i manage also the uh planning for the week you will receive the news related to my view
the fundamentals of asset managers so i will give you a breakdown on the indices
related to commitment of traders non-commercial so the speculators to build the narrative
and then i will update you on what was not planned to be okay that i kept because i only want people
that are really interested and to make them some surprise makes me happier that promise up front and
then not give a service that change really their view of the market okay so at the moment i'm building
a chat bot okay that where i input around 50 hours of my time that is capable to be your assistant
okay so i will not be there with you every single time when you are trading i will be here with you two
two times per week but what i can do is transfer my mindset model in the chat bot okay in the artificial
intelligence transfer exactly my risk management model in the artificial intelligence to give you an
opportunity every time that you are on the charts by yourself to implement it and study and reason as i
as if i was there with you what do you think fabio about this setup how much should i risk i took three
stop loss for the day how can i improve it okay today is getting difficult the market i cannot manage it
what should i do stop and i will apply the exactly months mindset model that i use for my trading okay
this one will be available for all users okay and will be ready before the end of the month
then another thing that we will have here is the following we will have
the battlefield that was a chat that was not planned to be because it should be a communication with
me and you the battlefield it's a chat between
these one percent members okay where i will review every evening and make sure that people that are in
the battlefield so the chat where there is execution where there is setups where they can go through are
people that are profitable and are people that can really give back to the community okay so if you
are really willing to study but you are in the process you are not profitable you will be able to see the
battlefield chart but you will not be able to participate in the battlefield chart because you can give in
sites that are not good for the community because you are still in the process of getting profitable okay
the battlefield chat will be available for everyone but will be open only for certain people that i select
okay is it clear guys one one in chat don't get offense it's to give you the best quality service you can have around
perfect after this you have what is called now files i will update to resources
resources and resources it's the access every week to the best
bank report and research paper that i study okay so in the weekend as a professional i spend at least one
or two hours researching the most important view of the biggest bank in the world so goldman sachs morgan
stallley what are they doing what's their view for the next quarter on indices okay what's their view on
the logic related to behavior of the market are they waiting for a news to unlock or are they already with a clear
buys why because in this way you can apply your model following the fundamentals so if you already
know that in three days there is the cpi and the market is in compression maybe it's not the best thing
to do to go trend following okay so i'm giving you the opportunity to see what i see and know what i know from
the point of view of indices so nasdaq okay followed by the best banks in the world we will cover the top five
banks in the world other than that i know that i did more than two thousand and three hundred execution
in the most famous audit world cup of the world that you saw me live trading for a huge amount of
months that you are joining this live charting program so we will see set up together we will commend them
but if you have any doubt that what i'm teaching you maybe is something that is subjective i will upload
you the research paper that will give you the understanding of the biggest institution and
university in the world of why volume is the best data you can use for trading okay i will upload certain
research paper that demonstrate the relationship between volume and price okay so when i see big
trades big trades is giving me an insight not only of what's happening now but also what's
happening next this is an edge this is an informational edge clear for everyone guys three in chat
this session you need to have a little bit of patience because before going to the chart
to the explanation we need to go a little bit through what this program includes okay we will do
from this week till the last week of march okay so we will cover all the q1 and i say two lives per week
but it's possible that if the weekend i'm free on sunday i will go live okay i will send a message and
i will go live because i don't watch at the clock i don't care maybe one time one one session the market is
this job is not very interesting we do one hour maybe one session the session it's amazing i want
to explain to you we do four hours okay maybe one sunday okay i see something that i want to comment
with you based on macro we go live even if it's not scheduled i will send you a message and you can join
and if you cannot join you will be able to find all the recordings guys in the section okay so you will
have a section with one second i want to let me see if i can remove the notification a lot of people
are talking and this is giving me a lot of ah but i think you cannot hear can you hear notification
i don't think so let me check
no i don't think you can hear is it bothering you okay no notification so it's perfect
okay okay if you cannot hear it's not bothering you while you fall okay so research paper on why
volume okay in this program this live charting program i will debunk you
the reason why you lost money following gurus okay so i will not go politically correct
i will explain you exactly why what you think psychology is lack of understanding why because
95 percent of the guru in the space are building a cult to sell you something but they don't trade
themselves and this is a problem because what can you expect from this of course you cannot expect
anything capable of giving you an edge okay so we will not go easy on this today
session we start let me clear everything for you today's session we start with my main
order flow models okay that we will use through all the lives so i think it's better
for people that are in the study phase or that wants to go just 20 minutes through all the process okay to be able
to see uh together what we will be going to use today so if they have any doubt okay they will be able
to go back to this lesson when we do live charting and go back and see ah okay that's the reason why fabio
is waiting for along here because this is the reason because this is the confirmation and he using a
momentum model or is using a trend following model or is using a mean reverting model for what he explained
in the first live do you agree guys two in chat two i will interrupt just one second perfect i will interrupt
just one second the screen share so i will be able to set everything in choose screen give me one second to be able to set
okay okay this one is here
okay should should be perfect to start one second guys now we start with the sauce
just one second
amazing okay now i go on share screen again
and we can start
okay give me one in chat if it's visible back again for you the screen we are still using excalibur
can you see it
perfect
okay okay now let me see here
okay
okay we can also remove this to not have notification bothering me
amazing amazing amazing so what we will cover
we will model okay that i use for nasdaq specific and we will cover also what's related
to the execution logic okay
okay so we will start from the market scenario and behavior and i think we can go directly
to today's session later okay so we will even if it's the first
program we can already start charting today okay i think it will take me around 20 minutes maximum 30
minutes to go through the model and we will go in
in the practice so you have practically three model i want you to save this okay you have the model where
the market it's in a balance phase
okay
this model is working really good when you are closed inside the previous
i want you to go through the model i want you to go through the model i want you to go through the
cash session okay and we can make a lot of money with this
by trading the absorption
at the top with the big trades how many of you did this guys give me one in chat
and trading look at people in shots already milking and trading the absorption of the sellers
on the downturn okay this model is mean reverting is making you me today stm amazing this model is
making you a lot of money when the market is stationary okay and you have two opportunity the first
opportunity is to trade from the bottom to the poc the second opportunity but this is when the profile
framing is aligned and we will go through it is trading from the bottom to the value area i and
also trying to take a sniper at continuation okay i will give you immediately an example about this or
don't worry we will go through everything you learn don't worry any doubt that you have the reason i
capped the the slot and the reason i didn't let the beginner in is because i know that all the
questions that you will make it's a smart question so for you it will be really easy to receive my support
okay now i'm talking about cash session okay so i will make it easy just give me
one second i give you this explanation this is the up phase this is the down phase okay so the other
opportunity you can have is this you have absorption at the top one two you have absorption at the bottom
you fade the absorption at the bottom to go back
to this okay so to the poc
but the absorption at the top you want to go to the value area low and potential breakout why is this
i will explain you this i will explain you this to take a decision if you want to do this game using
the cache session okay in mean reverting remember this is a mean reverting
balance model to understand this you need to understand before where you are in the profile framing okay
now the profile framing it's based on the volume profile i have some people that text me fabio look
i'm beginning to trade i'm using the profile the volume profile of trading view can i use the volume
profile of trading you guys is not using real volume but i use both of them side by side and the distribution
is it's not changing like the uh order flow related to footprint it's changing a little bit the distribution of the cache session
it's almost the same okay there is no big change about this so you can use without any problem okay
but if you have a professional order for platform okay it depends on what you you prefer i use deep charts and i participate in alpha research for deep charts
you can use this template that is already available okay this template here it's what i use to do profile framing
okay when we do profile framing we want to understand who is in domination of the market so
so if this is the
gauss distribution of the session of monday okay
this is the gauss distribution of the session
of tuesday okay this is the gauss distribution
of the session of wednesday what the market is telling me guys in in chat
the value is building up okay so if the value is building up i do profile framing and i mark the
best areas okay so i mark this value area low that is also overlapping with the previous value
area high and if the market goes back to this value area low of the cash session the next day
i have not only this move back to poc i have also this move back to value rei and i have the
continuation this is exactly when i want to use this model is it clear now for you so the first
step is profile framing when we are long on the profile framing okay and i see the market being
choppy so i have the session of today maybe that is closed here inside if i have to choose one
position mean reverting i go back for example from here to poc but if i need to choose from the bottom
line i go for extension okay 100 clear perfect the opposite is for this the opposite is for this we
have maybe uh let me go on white we have maybe monday tuesday overlapping here you can merge these two
profiles you can merge remember and then i have a shift down okay for a shift i mean that the value area
low is lower and the value area high is lower this is your delta in shift of the single session okay
now in this case i have two sensitive area one is the value area i as we saw before for the session
and another one it's the poc as we know no the poc of the single session it's important it's important
this and it's important also the poc of the session that created a breakout then we will go to see of
course we will see roy then we will go to see the example that i took live uh how many of you guys
saw the session of 50 000 that i uploaded on youtube please watch it it's a session where i took this play
it's a session where i took this short play okay on the test and i monetize all the collapse down
all the collapse down also with a confirmation of aggressive buyers not managing to break the top
okay and this was uh was something incredible because the risk was really low on this position
so remember that in this case you have sensitive level one and cluster two poc and value rei when you
reach here maybe this is the session of today okay we are starting inside the cache so we are mean reverting
i see the market going here i see one trigger from order flow i apply this model
can i go on is it clear for everyone so i'm still mean reverting but the execution logic is not cutting my
position you see because i'm in line with the institutions okay clear amazing now for this model
that is the model related to mean reverting guys you want me to uh to add also a little bit of
fundamentals because on this model i apply also the commitment of traders report so if you want i can
give you the blueprint okay let's do it you go on trading star you go on trading star and you watch
specifically this is giving you code report with interactive charts okay and i will share in the chat
and i will send you here
okay so in the chat you can click there is the commitment of traders here and you can go with me
directly to indices okay and we will go one by one we will start the first one and we open the
cut report of s&p 500 okay the cut report of s&p 500 it's on the long term from asset managers non-commercial
it's asset manager let me go through this explanation because this one is a multi-day model or a single
day model but it's a logic that use the fundamental data
okay so you want to follow institutions institutions are non-commercial and asset managers okay part of the
asset managers and leverage money
okay exactly do exactly as i do hamet so you go here you go in the first line okay this one you don't need
to click not cut futures not cut legacy you go directly here you go in the section indices and
you click on the legacy one here okay so what we are seeing now on this one is the long-term positioning
let's check ud2 is saying that it's laggy for everyone else the live is working good it's just him
because my connection is it's amazing like i i have more than 2 000 megabyte in download and upload
amazing okay so it's just him okay now 370 000 against 248 000 what does it mean guys we mean that we
have a skew okay if we mean if we have a skew on this one it means that the skew it's on the short side for the institution
for 122 000 contract okay 122 000 contracts multiplied by 50 dollars per contract okay it's an exposure
of multiple millions okay in terms of skew now when we think about the skew of the last release okay the last
release is telling me that in the short side they added 35 000 in the long side they added 20 000 so
there is a skew of another 15 000 on the short side is it clear so they are on the long term they are
already short on the shorter they added some longs and some short probably this is for coverage okay but
they added 15 more shorts so their overview is still short now i show you how they are synchronized
okay this is the s p 500 let's go on the nasdaq
is the nasdaq in agreement with the last release yes or no they added 3900 shorts
and they added only 400 long okay nasdaq is still more skew on the long side than s p 500 but we want
to see mainly the last release because it's telling us who is putting the feet on the gas
and this is a release on the this release let me call some dow jones it's on the 13 okay so it's of the
last week it's updated on the dow jones we are neutral in long term and we added 5700 short against 2200 long
the last release is this the changes okay you always need to check
check the net so they had 500 and seven five thousand and seven hundred short they added 2200 long
it means that they have that 3400 500 short more is it clear for everyone or no no no no i don't check
this every day mark here i only check this when the new release comes out i'm explaining to you because
this one it's extremely useful when you align it with the profile framing so the institutions from the
last release that was the 13 okay of january are telling you we are distributing orders their exposure
is going short okay the option flow is not related with hyperscalping the options is an information that
i use for more long term not for hyperscalping okay so they are distributing order amazing intel i i like that
you enjoy carlos okay so when we see that they are distributing order from the 13th of january
and we go back to price and we go back to price and we see that the 13th of january was exactly on the value
area i now this rejection at the top of the value area you see this line is the value area i know
they start to make sense yes or no these three days of distribution they start to make a lot of sense
okay and what's good and the reason people lose money by using cot because they don't understand it
is that once you have a framework for the indices
okay you can cross confirm the s p 500 the nasdaq and the dow jones and the russell if you want
and you can build a matrix okay you can build a matrix and if
majority of them have a last change with strong short exposure okay and for short strong exposure
i mean that the delta is 30 percent let's say for example if they add 1 000 long and they add
5 000 short for me it's a strong skew they expect the market to go down the last week okay and what
if one is long and the other one is short in this case i'm at let's say for example that they add
they it's short here okay it's closing 2000 contract it's even better because they close negative no
they close 2000 contract long and they open 5 700 short it means that the delta now is 7 000
so they are even more convinced to go short okay i can give you an example on the crude oil if i'm not
wrong the last release of the crude oil was like this not this but the release of sixth yes look at this
okay on crude oil okay on crude oil you have 4 800 contracts short added so they have a bias in view on
the short and they also say on the long side i closed 2 400 contracts so they have a net short in bias
of more than 7 000. is it clear now
okay for the indices yes you can check that you can check the american indices
so now going on this on the first model okay we are inside here and we don't need to guess
only only non-commercial robin i only watch non-commercial why i only watch non-commercial
because non-commercials are speculators are asset manager are leverage money they need to make money by
the price moving commercial have different objective not reportable or retail i want to see the whales
what their whales are doing okay and when you cross-reference this when you cross-reference this and you go
for example
you go for example on
the nasdaq no sorry the the s p 500 cut legacy you can go down and watch it deeper okay let's do a game
let's do a game guys because this is how the market move without fluff without type and without
anything else that can only waste your time you remove no reportable and you remove non-commercial
you amplify this okay and you make it bigger
okay so what we are doing now is we are watching s p 500 max exposure okay for timeline what's the
biggest cell exposure that you see in this chart okay you can see the cell exposure that is the
biggest on may okay they started to sell heavy in beginning of may okay and in beginning of may
what you can see is that the market had a strong move down okay had a strong move down if we reference this
to the last price action to the last year okay and we go to see here what happened we had a top in non-commercial
on november okay a top in non-commercial in november from november they only distributed volume so
so let's go here and let's go back okay let's go to november
okay this is november is the fact that institutions distributed money coherent with volume yes or no
it's of course it's coherent they sold the l but when they sold when they sold guys let's let's check
let's check they start the cell exposure really strong from the buy level 12 of november from that
moment they never recovered okay perfect we start to go down with a strong shift look here okay when we
start to go down shift here up move switch of behavior and is exactly the beginning of november
okay and they went down here till the 21 of november so you have a skew between the data and the actual
result that it's incredible okay it's the same now i'm showing you
this one okay i don't have on the chart but if we want to go
on 2025 we can go in march okay you remember in march what happened we had a sudden move down
from the indices and this movement was supported by fundamentals if we go here in the last release
okay and we watch the last exposure we go in non-commercial from
82 000 to minus 94 000 to minus 105 to minus 121. this is billions of exposure what do you think the market will do
what do you think the market it will dump there is no other way around guys okay and what it's doing
is going down for all the following weeks okay now this movement that the market is doing one guy is
asking was it predictable for you guys for people that saw my profile framing on deep charts what i said
for this coming week these slides were still not open what i say what i can expect
i can expect i can expect a dump okay i can expect a dump okay that the 25 200 will be it you remember
look at this level okay it went to the value area low really close but i think we eat let's check if we
it in the pre-market let's check 25 000 here we go look here look here in the cash session opening
25 000 and two one the bam okay they went even lower
yeah and they will eat a wall exactly what happened okay but this is something that we are doing
already from months okay and we will do also here because when you have everything when you have the
information related to volume you can build your narrative okay now someone is asking fabio but why
if the data are short on this side you expect that in the following week
we will go from the value area low that we already touched here
why do you think we will go
up here and i think you can understand when you understand this chart
you can understand that the maximum exposure they have it's on the long side for the short term
okay they are just taking profit here on this level on the level that we saw and we marked together
but if we go on the long term and we see they approach this level multiple times okay look here
the first time that they approached this level
this level was here and they had this retracement in thermal volume okay then
we take this level again we reject really strongly this is a super important level from the sellers
this time the movement that we achieve from this level is this one
okay after this we go close and we do another movement and now the price is rejecting here going back
inside the range okay in this case what i can expect from the session of today is not continuing lower
because i already gave the level it was the 25 219. i expect this to to close
in the middle of this two session okay in the middle in this area
okay why i expect it to close and i'm explaining all my process all my process from a to b
because now we are going above the value area and the market is out of a consolidation phase so now
it's a moment for the market to build up okay to build up and if we think about this
let's think about this no if the market wants to build up what what is the most important level
of control the market can find on the way up the market can find on the way up is the first point
of control that is this so it's a test of the ceiling of the previous week okay this was the law of the
previous week in terms and then we have other targets here okay but when we go now i want to go
immediately to charting but i need to explain before the the models okay but when we go on the
because this was the best opportunity of the day when we go here on the deep trades for the chat
can you explain to me what you see in this cluster and in this cluster
look at the level okay the price tapped into the level that i already saved 220 we have a strong
rejection this is incredible positive delta the buyers are getting rewarded they are extremely
aggressive on the level they reload here and what is more important you know what is more important
than everything else that these buyers when sellers try to engage the level here they say
where do you think you are going where do you think you are going and i i don't think this one
will uh finish finish faster this movement i think we are just starting the momentum of the day
okay what the market is telling us with this candle like i want to explain but i also want to
chart with you but but i need to understand that we will have a lot of session okay what the market
is telling you look i try to be to break above the level of absorption that i had before okay i try to
back up above i managed to do it now what you need now you need sellers that try to push the price down
but they cannot you see how much they are trying probably soon you will see some aggressive sellers that
got absorbed okay that punched a wall and where you can find these sellers we don't need to guess
too much we can help each other so the first information we have is that the value area of
the cash session is on 25 392 and the price as you can see you see how much it's having a hard time
breaking it these are important level guys you see that it's with this line it's inside it's not easy for it
to break it and it's going up and down is it clear i don't know guys if it's clear you can see but
this line this white line trying to break the cash session and then getting rejected back down is it
visible is this line here amazing okay so this is a decision level and you have this decision level
marked in red you have this decision level marked in red and what you can see here is that the sellers
every time they engage the 25 390 they are trying to keep it down okay this is the exact ceiling of the value
area this is the level that is trying to push the price down now what's funny is that if we manage
to break this level that is also the previous absorption
okay if we manage to break this level we have a gap and this gap
is the first level that the market will aggressively want to rebalance
if we break this value rei is it clear all the reasoning and someone can ask fabio but why
because market maker don't like inefficient transaction they make money only when the
market is efficiently transacting so my playground for the day okay my playground for the day will be
seeking this momentum explosion okay we'll be seeking this momentum explosion from the moment we clearly
accept before the above this cluster okay if it reach the gap will it spike i think we will see a good
up movement i think the momentum will catch up the moment we reach this high and you will see an
aggressive movement up with first strike second strike third strike and if it arrives here it's a masterpiece
okay this is the playground now when we go on the long term okay we cannot shoot for a target that is
for example here but why we cannot shoot for a target that is here because if we do our usual
profile framing analysis in yellow we understand that for the multi-day pressure the pressure is still down
is it clear
amazing so you need also to understand what the market is telling you now let's go on because we saw together
we saw together the framework using fundamental analysis and single day and multi-day profile framing
plus the confirmation of the consolidation phase to get mean reverting execution that are
stealing candies to the market now if this is clear i can cancel this is my video that i did on the
psychology i use the same framing i hope you like it and we can go on the second model the second model
probably is the one that will present today it's the momentum model okay the momentum model during the
christmas vacation gave me an incredible idea okay so i improved it so everyone that also saw it and
studied it i'm working a lot on improving my models okay and the logic that i did okay uh on this it's
trying to understand how i can catch the best movement of the market adding confluence to know
that the market will not catch me movement like this break out and that's not back okay but that i will
only take the movement that are like this okay and this requires me a lot of study on research paper
on how i can how i can get deeper into the micro mechanics understanding the interaction of the orders
and the location of the orders so the momentum model for people that follow it
was the following we have a balance okay this can be either a session profile so the actual cash session
so the cash session start here and the actual cash session shows you the market going like this
okay and then you break it okay and when you break it you have a potential to have a momentum setup okay
but this one when you become advanced okay they work amazingly amet because these models are built
on the language of the market they are not built on optimizing parameters when you get advanced you can
also use the fixed profile how many of you guys use the fixed profile the fixed profile it's incredible
it's incredible because it lets you put your skills and understanding of the market
working for you at leverage so for the session profile usually what you will have noticed him
is that you have one or two opportunities per day because you have only one session profile when it
break the cash session you have the explosion and that's the setup okay but when you understand that
you can have point a and point b on your swing point okay and maybe the swing point it's like this
impulse in the beginning then consolidation phase and then consolidation phase here okay and you get your
fixed profile from the point a to the point a to the point b what your fixed profile will show you a
distribution that is like this okay a distribution that is like this now you are not slave to one or two
opportunity per day but you can do what the other guy was telling uh it was enrico enzo i don't remember
and no hyperscalping because you you can have also five ten opportunities per day because every swing
point you know how to read and how to identify so the moment from this distribution we will do this and
accept what do you think will give us the test usually gives us an impulsive move down okay usually gives us
an impulsive move down and this is exactly what i think we can see today when the price break
this distribution we are now here we are trying to break this cash session and we are rejecting rejecting
what i expect today is this and a huge move up okay exactly exactly this is the momentum model then i was
thinking sometimes maybe it break a little bit and come back inside i don't know how many of you had
this problem that in consolidation session sometimes you get an amazing execution put your stop loss to
break even and then the market comes back and you say okay i had the opportunity to close at one to two
but the market came back perfect then the the the other hour the market break again and snap back inside
this one it's a market behavior that i seen a lot of times during mid-december from the last two weeks
of december and the first 10 days of january have you experienced this guys choppy market every
breakout comes back in so this market is really boring for me okay yes you can take some one to one
and one to two but it's really difficult to take one to three one to four one to five one to ten one to
twenty like the one that i took in the video because the market is consolidation so i think i spent more
than 50 hours researching and i find something this is something that i never explained okay i find
something that changed the momentum model in a way that it's incredible okay and it's the study of not only
the aggressive market participants filtered for size so what we call the big trades okay it's not only this
it's not only the big trades but is the study of the speed of these participants okay so i added to this
this the confluence of the speed of orders what is called the speed of tape you want to see which
kind of cheat code it is we go on the on today look at this cheat code okay you open the chart and in the
level that i show you this was the best opportunity for today in the opening okay unfortunately i was
preparing the live for you with all the topics so i didn't at the time but when you go on this and when
you see that the market is giving you not only big strong aggression level plus cluster of speed of buy orders
you see here how many blocks outline of buy orders we have and you see how these big trades gets confirmed
look at this 60 locked the level no look at this big orders okay look at this speed of tape okay what
the market is telling you you not only have an amazing cluster of aggressive older on this horizontal
level but you are also supported by speed guys it's really easy to read you need to read deep green candle
and deep purple candle if you want to go short ignore all the rest ignore this you know i i can also give you
this visual i can also give you this visual
i think it's easier for you to understand like this
okay it's easier okay treat this as an histogram okay this one this surge in aggression of the volume of
the buyers is telling you the auction is done expect an explosion up okay and this is the reason they
come back here and we have this amazing move look here stable stable stable stable again two of those
where let's put this area under the scan and what we see that is the locking of this starting of the move
see this is the starting of the move now it's amazing because the marketing telling you there is
nothing there is nothing here and you want to see how you can avoid a lot of stop loss look here look
how much is low the activity if you try to take this breakout you will have incur in a lot of losses but
look here do you understand the value of these guys one in shot it's keeping you out of useless moment
in the market it's keeping you out you are not participating in moments where you could have only
taken stop loss let's say for example that you want to try along here okay you see that it's empty
and you would have taken a stop loss but with this you only get in movement that are sustained by the
speed of tape okay now we have we don't have anything no big trades and no speed of tape but soon
remember what i'm saying to you i know i know this chicken i trade the nasdaq from half my life
okay i know look look look look soon the buyers will get control and we will see this level populated
by aggressive orders they are testing they are poking they are trying to take control of the levels
imagine this as a risk you know what is a risk it's a war game where you have your tank and you
need to conquer other areas okay what they are doing now is trying testing you saw before was all
green now the sellers are loading really heavy really fast and now the buyers are responding look
you can see this in real time it's amazing okay look how they are responding they are saying no
no no no no my lovely seller you can load as much contract as you want i control the level you see
the result of the buyers you see the result of the buyers they close green even with all these sellers
and look how many sellers are loading sellers are loading so fast but what you see buyers are standing
their ground okay buyers for now are standing their ground and from where they will continue to
stand their ground till the beginning of the move the beginning of the move started here
okay so you can expect that all this speed of the sellers will be absorbed in this area now there is
no participation from aggressive orders guys i really try my best only to explain models for the first session
but then i see the market and i cannot help myself to analyze
and you see here what we are having what we are having at the moment we are having a speed of tape
controlled by sellers okay we are having a speed of tape controlled by sellers they have more pressure
than the previous moment and we have buyers that are not interactive before they were defending
now they are not interacting and look at this big orders and speed of tape oh today nasdaq is really
participating in giving you the best understanding what you see here they stepped in to defend the level
with 124 horizontal contract okay horizontal contract with a speed that was visible immediately they
printed a candle like this what did what this mean that they input this contract fast one single
order 124 contract on nasdaq guys it's a nominal value of more than 100 million
more than 100 million guys you understand who are these people that are playing this game here
and who we are watching to build our edge these are big money this is not me this is not carmine this
is not tomorrow these are people that can buy us okay with one trade
and then you see the auction is fighting they define the bottom of the range and then they define the top of
the range the auction is starting okay they have the speed they have the volume and they have the direction
yes guys thank you jason this is not a signal service please this is my years of knowledge in the chart
at your service to understand how i make money okay please don't execute use this for educational purpose
try to understand what i'm teaching you okay try to understand what i'm teaching you because the best
gift you can give to me is taking this trade by yourself it means that my time got rewarded
yes speed of tape is helping you speed of tape it's like a validation of the most important aggressive
orders okay you see what i told you we have defined the top of the range and the bottom of the range
from this level you see what they tried they say let me see if i can
okay let me see if i can and what's the reply of the sellers i think you still cannot i think you still cannot
okay now this behavior it's the potential beginning of the move of the day
breaking the value area imagine how much it's important this fight that we are watching now
this fight that you are watching and you say ah maybe i can enter one contract and i make 100
dollar is the fight that is defining how on the 20th january billions of dollars are being moved
okay billions of dollars are being moved and this level that i marked is the level that they use for
intermediate cross reference
okay intermediate cross reference
now this level here it's becoming an important level and you know what's the reaction of the market
by the moment they break an important level you have an aggression on the upside and you don't come back
you have a squeeze you have what i like to call a squeeze
okay you see how they are trying
see how they are trying they are putting after i for now expect that they print a green candle because
they are loading hard so expect that they print and expect that we start to see aggressive buyers
aggressive buyers aggressive but bam okay these sellers are not holding back
these sellers are not holding back
no no no no no no you could have enter amand also at this the the white line is the point of no return
the white line is the point of no return because when they break this level now we are in a super
sensitive level you know what's this week this week is the value area high absorption you see is that the
same level they already told us before now try to enter in the head of the market if we manage to break
this level with participation and absorption all these sellers needs to close and if all these sellers
needs to close they push the market really fast to the next station and which one is the next station
the next station on the upside that we have is this one 460 is the last station no
this is the last station if i'm not wrong yes it's this one this is the last station for me
stay with me be patient learn learn how to
get in tune with the market is telling you
you need to understand every single candle because every single candle is telling you a story
now they are telling you the most sensitive level are this and this
who won these buyers won what does it mean that probably if they come back to test we will reject again
they are not leaving the bag every time they get pushed down by sellers they recover the level
you see what you see how they behave guys
see this is the the bus the pass through level they push it down and they reload they push it down and
they reload expect to see something here really soon expect to see something here really soon
because i can see that the interaction is really aggressively really aggressively
they had a reload here they had a reload if you want to see a reload really fast without changing the
settings of your big trades we can mark this last movement with profile and see
what's the most important price level look without without anything else
clear for everyone or no guys doesn't get easier than this it doesn't get easier than this
guys have you noticed that i didn't put a delayed live
have you noticed that i'm not going live with a 20 30 second one minute delay
notice this
notice the difference
they are pushing it back again
now this level is accepted this is the last station of the sellers i think we will print really soon
a huge green candle here on the on the speed of tape on the speed of tape
they are aggressively breaking they are aggressively breaking the cash session high
guys i don't know if you understand that already from the moment i told you this is control of the buyers
mid of the candle this is already enough for the day this is already a one two three
now this is not the final target of course but just to understand that you don't need to get a sniper
look look look look what we are doing look at the sweep look at the sweep this got absorbed
this one got absorbed so the seller are actively participating above the eye okay and this is a strong
a strong information that they are not letting the buyers they control okay look at this look at this they
are not letting the buyers they control and you need to become good at reading this
now this one creates a secondary setup that is one of my favorite setup no now the framework is clear
and we have two clean point of battle the first one two three is gone but look at this we have two clean
point of battle one and two okay this is the two clean point of battle the reloading
if we manage to break this point okay we can use the profit of the first position
to shoot for another one to two no sorry way more because a lot more seems way more higher the target
so one to twelve to be honest with a break even here
but you need to wait for a breakout
this is the level
guys as always it's not financial advice it's my view of the market this is for educational purpose
you see what i told you they absorb the buyers and they go to test back here okay this setup
it's not activating if you don't break the top because it means that the sellers are in control
here now look at this level this is the first level that we saw this is still a valid setup but
now the stop loss is too long they absorbed here and they came back to the origin point now look at this
look at this level look at this level you see that the market slides through everything and the first
pose that the market had is on this level what does it mean that they have the only protection point
of the buyers okay this is the only protection point of the buyers if this one gets broken we will go
back here before breaking the top because today i'm really convinced that we will break the top okay
on the cash session
they eat the 124 contract with this 84 and one important stuff what happened in the speed of date
what you can see
seller's aggression now you understand why i say take out one two three it's enough and
reload risk this profit on the next one because when the market is mean reverting and what i explained
in the beginning that when we don't break the value area i okay this one it's an anticipation setup but
when we are inside what we do we mean revert to the top to the bottom you remember what we saw in the
beginning is it clear guys this doesn't mean doesn't mean that the bias is going short okay but this
means that probably we will tap into this law this means that we will tap into this law so we can clean the
chart and continue
this one
it's what price action traders call
the fake out this is not a fake out guys this is an absorption
this is buyers trying to take control
and get rejected do you consider level where market close and opens if we build new value but following
they open to the other side so it's better to away from the value what is the plan of the day
i don't use this darko i don't use opening and closing price i use only the cash session
how about the candle 511 with strong speed of tape big trade signal as well but then the buyers
are absorbed it's part of the game it can happen it can happen 511 it's here yeah it can but here
you see where we are where is this candle it's on the value area i so you need to understand this
let me clarify for everyone this
if you are here in the distribution okay and you have high speed of tape here and aggressive big trades
and speed of tape here you don't have a wall on the top so at least to the poc you have a huge
probability of arriving you understand the difference between the candle of 511 and the level 25 218
where i was searching for my first long
yeah it was a good short on the failed auction but i told you immediately you saw that the buyers
got absorbed this is a level where i usually take out profits but if they break this level i reload
they are taking the low as i told you now this one becomes an area let me hide this
and remove this and remove this this one becomes an area where i want to see
the last point of aggression is this one no you see why the last point of aggression because it's
the level that created the most important breakout all this breakout of this area
so i mark this and what i see where are we now guys on the fixed profile where are we now
where are we now the value area low okay and on the value area low which level are the levels
most sensitive we have the sellers getting completely absorbed here and we have the sellers getting
completely absorbed here and then what we have we have a big participation of the buyers two points here
so we have this area
that if we see some aggressive buyers can be really interesting
now i put the risk to reward as a no-brainer but consider that we don't have oh it's already reacting
really good this one also going back to the top range it's a 1 to 2.5 okay this is how it comes use
and this is the perfect example for the guy that told me fabio what's the difference between these that
here you are high in the curve here here you are in the bottom of the curve how can you check the curve
using the value area okay you see that here you are on the value area low usually the value area
low act as a really strong support let me put it larger so you can see better let's activate also the speed of tape
and the speed of tape at the moment it's not participated by buyers and not participated also by sellers
now we go through it read one
guys already one hour do you accept if i go at least on other 40 minutes or you are busy guys okay
because i want really to see this cash session with you
now as you can see they are going back to this level this horizontal level is the value area low
and what you notice you notice that they are stacking by order at the bottom you notice that
every time they tap into the value area low they stack by order
stack by order here okay and you can see also from the momentum they are building the buyers are
really aggressive really really aggressive and now what you can see is that it's building a wall
an intermediate wall here and if they want to break it they need to show a little bit of aggression
from the big orders or from the speed of tape
yes yes yes tall friends the value area low consider the value area low like
a road okay a direction of the road if you break from the bottom you go south if you break from the
more the north you go long look at these amazing trades that we saw guys this is already one to one
now when you see something like this and you already break the level considering that we already saw a
one two three you can put your stop loss to zero okay look how much aggression we we are seeing on
this market i hope guys it's not too complicated is it uh is it clear everything i'm explaining look look
look what an explanation look what an example we had you you see now where institutions like to
load their order you see from which level they like to load their order
this is another one to 2.5 if it goes and they tell you something this is not even
the final target because as i explained to you this can become a 1 to 15
and it's still valid guys okay but you can have two approach either you say look i already have
3r for the day i take other two out i close 5r per day it's amazing for me or you can say
the market is choppy it goes up it goes down i don't like it i want to
i want to shoot for one good trade of 1 to 20 and make the profit of the week this is another approach
one good trade of the day it's done okay okay you see that these aggressive buyers are stacked at
the top here and these aggressive sellers are pushing back from the top against them
now when you reach the the base that is this one the base is the level where you finish the battle so
you you understand if these sellers that are participating here are winning or they are losing
okay now you understand you saw me also when i did the session of 50k that every time i'm in profit
5 000 10 000 i remove this out of the market now imagine if this instead of going break even you
have still your position in the market you are always in time to reload you see you are always in time
to reload if it breaks back above 63 okay you can still take another position but why leaving floating
profit on the market just break even just break even red one this one is not a move that is giving me
and now i want to go back we started the session explaining the behavior of the market when it's inside
the cash session uh value area i and value area low and the behavior when it's outside this behavior
here what is guys
this is balance okay when can we expect momentum when you break this level this mean reversion that's the
reason you need to be fast either you take a one to two okay and say okay where is the poc where is the
poc guys the poc is here okay perfect you take profit here or you are watching only this distribution
okay where is the poc a little bit above one to two it's okay i take out but i want to show you something
now break even or not break even you see how the price feels let me remove this you see how the
price fills our area is it clear for you why this is the best logic of identifying levels
look at this battle look at this battle aggressive buyers against aggressive sellers
this they decide on this level they decide on this level they decide if they break the value area low
this is the exact level where they decide if they break the value area low and we go down
because the buyers are tempted to save the price but they failed
okay and you remember that we marked all this area no
and this is the area where you want to understand the battle this one is one minute yeah you can use
also the range you can use also the range can you comment this for me 60 and 65 65 at the bottom of the
candle 60 in the body of the candle the candle is closing cell you see how much they are fighting
they are deciding it's a decisional point they are low in the curve and not only they are low in the curve
they are also in a situation where the market in this case here it's overextended on the downside
see the sellers
this one it's a moment where you can wait for a clean win of the battle who won this battle guys
who won this battle who won this battle who won this battle here
so let's say that you took one break even and three are okay is this a one to two that you can try
or no of course yes you are low in the curve you have a tight stop loss you have a potential risk to
reward of one to 2.6 and you have a really fast break even point why a really fast break even point
because if this area gets broken you can go risk free as fast as sorry for the terms guys
that's the reason i didn't put delay
because i want to show you the prediction ability in real time
look at this
amazing eh
who won this battle buyers again okay what i'm risking 1000 floating 2000 already risk free
you understand the peace of the mind of trading like this
look at this movement look how much the price it's aggressive when you get the right areas
look at people executing there making money
what an amazing session together guys i love to do this
i love to do this you are covered but look how much space the market covered in one single candle
someone john maria saying got it too
got it too you are out you are out
i cannot see properly but i think it took it oh no no no no it missed one tick
bam you are out
5.5 r for the day and one break even
look at this probably we took with that one candle stop loss the big move of the day imagine now
if it squeeze imagine now if it squeeze and this is how i make session of 50 000 risking 2 000 guys
because from here if i load 2 000 risk and i shoot for this high
it's more than 1 to 10 and if i shoot for
this
this is a 1 to 20 so it's risking 2500 to make 50.
look at this look at look at the people making money look at look at this small bastard already
you need to learn you don't need to make money on my shoulders look at the equity line in chat
ah
no no but i'm happy for you guys i'm happy that you are understanding properly the move is not finished
the move is not finished
the move is not finished guys they accepted they are reloading this contract
we are back to the cash session high i think we will need to rebalance a little bit of this movement
but i think in the next
three to four minutes we can go back to the top of the range and we if we manage to break we have an
amazing move
fabio the two trades i took were before you show them on the charts i took them after
understanding the level you talked about don't worry roy i will not ask for my shares of the profit
you can say it it's not a problem
it's not a problem you see what i'm telling you they are
they are balancing into all these inefficient all these inefficient price action okay
and they have these aggressive buyers that probably are trying to hold the price up let me
see the speed of tape speed of tape is loading a little bit on the downside
and then you you can use the for the profile because we have the area look how much we were
precise in the identification of the area and then we have the most important aggressive buy
level that is there and one small buy level that it's here but this is the most important one
i think this is the reloading level i don't see anything more important than this on the price chart
so this attempt to break got rejected
25 355 it's here to go long again you know that uh you are right you know that you are right that
this level is nothing bad this is a nice level this is a nice level and you are already 5.5 r so you
can just risk one hour but you need to check how the price interact when it arrives here for now
for now i can see that these aggressive buyers are interested you see they rejected already two times
i want to see if also this candle get rejected we have a micro squeeze on the way up so we have one
candle that recover recover all these movements and we work in
steps so they shoot another long candle here with a weak rejection and the next one break everything
you see it's the third rejection here let me mark the level
the horizontal level on the rejection
you see you see you see their game what they are doing it's like if they don't want to go below
this aggression point
look now look now how they will try to poke this level with a with a buy and a weak candle
look at this micro gap
this micro gap it's important
this is a level that if the candle close below this gap it can break this but if it recover we go up
they want to test this level and the first time that they test this level as i told you you will see
a week because there are a lot of pending orders here limit
micro gap up look at the first out touch look at the first touch look at the first touch look at the
first touch here one two
they cannot even reach it one look at this touch okay you see how look at how the limit order look
look look look look look look this is live guys it's not recording it's not back test okay as i told
you they will insist on this level two or three times before breaking with a squeeze
this is a really consistent pattern of nasdaq they are loading they are loading they are loading we
need a little bit of speed of tape that we don't have we don't have look at the level look at the
precision of the level
look at the precision of the level 25 406 not even one tick of drawdown
no speed of tape of the buyers the movement failed
and back to the other range now they are reloading now they are reloading and this time when they
reach this level they will break really aggressively they will not give you weak
anymore they will break aggressively and they will try to poke the next one
range chart when the market is really choppy
range chart when the market is choppy
closed in a range
you see that they didn't manage to reach it when they will reach again they will break
another confirmation of the absorption but in all this area i don't see aggressive buyers or
aggressive sellers they are just loading this is like what i was telling you now now they rejected
again okay look what happens when they touch they don't need to when they touch again this level
past bank 25 413 yes
if we use delta volume charts it's easy to see absorption i prefer like this i prefer look at this
reload on this level look at the value of this area look at the value of this area they didn't reach
it's like imagine a cascade of orders imagine a cascade of orders
imagine a cascade of orders
they failed again they didn't reach the level and the buyers from this horizontal area are still
protecting they are still protecting
one second guys i cannot watch the q and a and chart it's real time i don't have seconds more
than you it's real time
look at this level 25 406.75 watch this level closely you need to understand market micromechanics
likes me in this year 2026 and you will see that what you paid for the service is peanuts
still not managing to reach here we are really close
speed of tape almost loading the candle it's interesting what i told you watch the recording
there if you have time they will reject they will try the first time it will print up weak
we will reject the second one will be an amazing move
roy service already paid for itself with this session but you don't need to to go heavy
no i don't have gamma exposure now i'm just going with order flow
this is part of hyper scalping dark
we are almost there we are almost there they are building a ceiling here
they are building a ceiling and this is exactly what they do before giving an explosive move
this is exactly what they do before giving an explosive move because here
you have absorption absorption absorption absorption of the buyers
till the moment the limit order cannot keep
okay and you have but we need to touch this level to do this
we need to touch this level to have a move that it's worth they they went back to the low of the range
look at cbd you can but it's not necessary guys
no i don't have deep dom aside i only have the charts that you are watching and your charts
i'm sharing you the only chart that i'm using i'm focused here i'm watching big orders rejection level
and range of the day i'm only watching this they try to break the law
let's see if they go back to the level that the guy was saying 355 the beginning of the move the inefficient
now you see the difference between here and here here it's empty no speed of tape not only from
the buyers but also from the sellers there is no speed of tape
no not today it's possible that we do charting now and the last model we cover on thursday
it's possible then we go to the q and a rodan
it depends guys it's not hard because if you see here the origin of the movement is this they are
going to rebalance they this squeeze was the same one that you would have if they break this top so
they squeeze the low okay but the last movement that created a breakout is this acceptance okay so
now i want to see on this horizontal level what sellers are doing remember that we have all this
area that before gave us an amazing one to 2.5 and it's possible that we have another opportunity to
make another one to 2.5 risking one hour okay so in worst case scenario we close at 4.5 r in the best
case scenario we go at seven eight leonardo it's already in ah you took a short okay you took a short
from the movement you took a shot from the distribution and the absorption but here in the curve
i cannot give you advice but i would consider by taking a little bit of profit because this level already
proved itself we are reaching it yes how speed is related to volume and order you see how this level
it's important this is the previous candle that we saw you see how much this one it's important
let me remove this horizontal level and here you have again another potential execution this is another
potential execution it's another one to two now it can go also also above it can go one to two point five
this is another execution where you risk only a small part of the profit one hour
why it's interesting this one because we saw that when the market gets low in the curve we have
really strong rejection so we have all this area where we can cover ourselves behind and this is amazing
balance market balance market but you need to be quick yeah in balance market guys usually what they
do is supporting the low and selling the top so you need to be pretty fast but the good point about
balance market is that if you are smart in positioning and fast you can you can close the day at three
four five r also sometimes at seven eight r without too much effort you don't need to take the big move
you can take all one to 2.5 one to three one to four but a lot of them and only risking the profit
for example if we lose this trade we stop for the day because the market is not giving us
any explosion so we only can use the mean reverting model that already gave us enough profit
but we need a little bit of diversification no so when you go back here if you go back here
and the buyers take back control you can already go to break even on this position so you understand that
your risk it's time limited and that's the importance of being precise
that's the importance of being precise
if they break this candle from the bottom i would already like to be out so already is free you are
still 5.5 r in profit with the potential to make a one to two point five additional but you put the
risk out of the market in not even three minutes if it rejects and goes down you can try again this is
why you need speed am i clear guys true in chat you see all this rejection this is risky but you are
already out of the risk of the market you are not risking you are not participating in the risk
okay it would have taken money from us here but being fast and covering ourselves in precise area zero risk
okay yeah the move is weak now we are getting choppy market is getting a little bit choppy
but still it can pay us really good
so we took another break even we didn't took a single stop loss for the day
only break even and take profit why because we are fast
now when they break this level if they break this level
after tapping into
this one you have a big upside potential you have a smaller stop loss
because you have your stop loss below here if we have an aggression of the sellers with rejection and
aggression of the buyers okay you have a profit potential this level i don't want to put target
here because i know that we will squeeze up so here
with a really defined and small total risk here we go let's see if it close above
i would like to see a little bit of participation but i need to lower
the setting because the session is really choppy for the day
not not lunch break sleep break
this is a sleep break for the asset
okay we have at 40. you see what we can have here we have an interesting candle we can wait
to clean all this consolidation and then we drop our risk to reward tool you see how much it's
important waiting for speed of day big trades nothing there is nothing now they are going back to this level
you need to be patient here
you took break even lenardo you took a long
yeah i refer to vivo app legato
guys please use your first and second name so i can memorize the name and recognize the best trader
and the people that are inside the group don't use like names of cartoon or stuff because it gets
really difficult for me to remember the best traders the one that participate the most and i want really
to put you into the battlefield
yeah put put from the settings you can change your name
do it after i like this for longs because of cvd what is cvd saying
hey they are absorbing all this movement of the sellers got absorbed nice
really nice
it's not changing our viewer i still think we need to go back in this area
look at this two aggressive buyers that never got tested for the session these are the two most
important buy area for the day for this two
see what they do
this is the mean reverting model
we are still mean reverting guys but what i'm demonstrating to you is that you can make money
also mean reverting market
look we tap into what
60 contract that moved the price up before we have another opportunity
when you break this candle i'm waiting to load when i load the risk to reward tool it's an opportunity
i'm waiting to load the price up later we go later we go on the rating
this is one potential setup
it's an amazing one two three
it's an amazing one two three why because the price gave me
the confirmation that the sellers are not participating low in the curve so it's really
difficult for them to break this level at least for what they are saying now we are in profit 5.5 r
so losing one r will bring us at 4.5 so we can try an additional trade low in the curve
the buyers are having a micro gap i don't know if you see but they are having some micro gaps that are
potential point for accumulation and also if we break this level we will stop for the day
because the market is completing consolidation but still 4.5 r it's amazing if we manage to go up we
add to the 5.5 r 3 r so we go to 8.5 r that in a consolidation day it's a triple a session it's
10 out of 10 session and i will be super happy to share this session with you let's see how it goes
guys it's impossible for me to follow the market and reply to the chat wait one second
when i tell you ask me question you ask me question
look how sellers are aggressively trying to push the auction down but i don't see anything here
i don't see anything this is the huge fight see this is a huge fight between buyers and sellers
this is a huge fight
we are low in the curve so you can see buyers always protecting their position standing their ground
all right i forgot potential break-even point
or yes the the yellow line that you see the origin of the selling move is a potential risk-free point
you cannot see picture on live stream you cannot see my chart guys is it visible for everyone my chart
or no
okay so it's a bug only for you let me remove speed of tape so i can see the chart bigger maybe this is
the problem what the happened i don't have there but but you still can see where is the the stop loss
it's this red line i don't know why it disappeared but anyway maybe because it's smaller can make it oh
here it goes
you see that the sellers are really trying to push aggressively and the same participants that are
protecting here are the one that caught absorbed it before is them okay
it's not smooth as smooth as the other setup that we saw but this is a setup that can be interesting
why because either it goes to stop loss but if you start to load up we can see a fast move up that
recover all these cell moves and start to shoot up really fast to the target this is something that
you see usually when they attack the value area low
nice zone uh andrea says yeah it's a nice area it's a nice area the condition of the market
today is not the best it's a little bit choppy but it's it's still an amazing session guys 4.5 r
i will sign with my blood to make this return every day
hmm oh first absorption of the area
these aggressive sellers got absorbed and these aggressive sellers send us to stop loss this is the
first stop loss for the day we are a 4.5 bar now what we can do because you see what happened
what is this information guys this one
what is this information look at this this rejection can be taken if this candle close green
okay and we are still 3.5 and this can pay us at 2.78 okay 2.8 so we go from 4.5 to 7.5
of course remember what i told you the candle needs to close green now the effort is not being rewarded
but what you can see a huge absorption of the sellers from the buyers
so this is amazing now you are into now you are in the setup and this one i also want to tell you
something it's a shoot that you can try for the 5r this is one shot that you could try for the 5r
everyone longing everyone but use only the profit of the previous because this one is not triple a
the market is choppy super choppy
i don't see if he took us out
i think yes
let's see how it goes
aren't you expecting price to target the equal low liquidity before moving to the upside
i don't use the equal low liquidity i use absorption yeah there is a huge seller absorption these have
the potential to go up now on this one the area is this and it didn't touch the low of the area 25
1332 but if you want to be a little bit more conservative you can also use this area
but the risk to reward then it's not one to five it depends on your preference
i like this gap this gap is usually catalyst
so what happens that if the candle close green inside the gap so it tap into and reject it's
usually a catalyst candle so it's an explosion up candle buyer standing strong but not so strong guys
uh the area is getting weaker and absorption might be it it's possible it's possible but still this
one is low in the curve and it's an absorption of the sellers so it's a setup that have an explanation a
logical order flow explanation and when you are only using profit the worst that can happen is that
you close from five point r to 3.5 r because we take a second stop loss and then we stop
so as soon as you have a logic for each setup that you take that that have an edge
you can survive also the most boring days today it's a super boring day
look how they are dancing in this area a lot of absorption on the on the downside a lot of
absorption on the upside and they are closed inside this range one momentum setup can be the breakout of
this if they break could be a momentum setup best part is that it took a super consolidation
until you took one stop loss guys it's really rare that i close in red the day because i
increase the number of execution only when i took amazing setup like the first three that we took
and then on the second one i risk one arm so all these setups are offered by the snipers that we took in the
beginning it's okay oh we are already live from two hours
let's see what they do
now it's it's ultra choppy guys look how much it's choppy it's not moving anything it's three
candles overlapping so this took us out we are 3.5 r what do you want to do guys you want to continue
other 30 minutes or you are bored you want to continue you like it amazing we can continue guys but with one rule
we are 3.5 r now we try maximum other two execution okay and we keep our 1.5 r in profit deal
i'm still in the trade amazing i will not be still in the trader because they want the battle the sellers
so they they are really pushing down you see this level now the buyers are protecting from this
inefficiency we can wait for the breakout of this okay to try a long cover below this leg
below these candles that shoot all the way up to the range this is a one to four but you need to wait
for a clean breakout and acceptance a clean breakout and acceptance of the level
yeah i usually trade all the new york session i'm active i'm active
i don't live in europe powell i live in uae you see why i took the level here they rejected exactly
there they didn't close above what does it mean that the sellers are still stronger they will tap into
again this level see here all the levels needs to be studied properly what is this black box that we
mark that needs to be broken the origin point of the cell move still not ready to go up
still not ready to go up guys
don't try too long don't try to i already told you till they don't break this level it will not go up guys
which problem are you experiencing jason
you try to go long on this how many of you guys try to long this cell candle
this is not a smart move i think we have also speed of tape active all the sellers are in control here
what are you doing guys don't try to take a falling knife
the reason i mark areas and put this to reward is because if this area breaks you can put your limit
wait one second it's complete absorption of the sellers here
you need to be patient
now this level got broken which level we have interesting and we have this level here interesting
of the buyers of this area here this is nice they are reaching it they tapped into now
bubbles on micro nasdaq it's a reassurance it's nice
wait wait now we want to see how it unfold this absorption is taking place
but you see here
what happens on this level guys observe in real time what is happening on this level
read with me
you see that they are pushing back the buyers down there are a lot of passive buyers
passive sellers
passive sellers sorry absorbing the up move the aggression of the sellers
of the buyers the sellers are protecting this move so we can expect another leg down here we go
read price and volume together
if we want to take other snipers amazing like this read price and volume together
we want to take other snipers so we want to see interest from buyers
we want to see interest from buyers as of now they are pushing below the big orders there
is a lot of aggression of the sellers i would wait
i would wait and if we want to go even deeper
we are
269 it's interesting
this is the level where we are actually
so
this buy that created this area is not bad
the origin of the move from aggressive orders is this one let me clear all these levels
okay
what's happening here
what's happening here guys
it's not absorption
it's not absorption the sellers
are getting rewarded
they are managing every single candle you see every single candle it's printing a lower wick or a lower body
there is no sign of buyers
there is completely no sign of buyers
zero
what we need to do is to wait for the battle to get in our direction
if we want to go long we need to wait for the battle to get in our direction
now you notice what
this week
here contains the next week
this week here
i anticipated what i wanted to say this week here contains the next body
they are starting to decelerate to fade
this week here is the next week here is the next week
okay when you have a confirmation that this deceleration and control of the buyers is getting back
when you see aggressive orders not at the top but in the body of one candle
okay i prepared this
and we go to see it when it unfolds
buyers are engaging but they are not accepted you see
they are still losing to the end of the seller
unfortunately
guys i'm going
if you are tired don't worry you can watch it later but i'm going because i want to
to see the levels of the session with you
the best supplement for monitoring stress
stress is ashwagandha is keeping cortisol under control if you want and if it's something
interesting for you in the community i can share with you my supplement phase with everything that
i day that i take that is proven by by science to make your mind easier and stress lower okay there
is a lot of stuff i i can share in the group with research also yeah we can do it we can do it you
see they they went back to the lower point and now they are trying to break the top if they manage
to break the top the buyer's momentum is confirmed so if they manage to break this top with a full candle
the buyer's momentum is confirmed
and here it is
okay
zero draw down my position amazing tell this is a setup
i know that maybe it's too much in target that i want to put on this one but this could be
a one two
three here a one two
one two five also this could be a one to five it's not wrong as an analysis
i don't like the market condition today i would take this setup for the last one and in the worst
case scenario close that at 2.5 r in a super choppy day value very high to value area low it just filled
just filled from the bottom let's see how it goes look how much strong are sellers this movement of
the buyers input a lot of aggressive volume on the upside a lot of aggressive volume on the upside we are
low in the cure in a set in a sensitive area after this control of the buyers but still they the sellers
have a strong hammer guys sellers have a strong hammer
let's see seems to be a little bit protective the buyers
makes sense to put the position to cover
at this level so we close anyway maybe with a 3.5 r and we secure more profit for the day let's see how it goes
if they manage to catch up above this eye
they will squeeze
okay risk to zero worst case scenario we close 3.5 r in the best case scenario we close 8.5 r
but with this market guys i don't like to say it by expect i expect that we go back down then we go
back up so this is a a strong move when the conditions are good it puts you really fast in stop
loss to zero you so much nicely tested
and i took a look at the take profit where i put at the origin of the levels that i told you before
but you can also decide to close at one two three and have 6.5 r for today yeah it's amazing guys
in a consolidation day 6.5 r it's amazing i take one glass of water guys and comes back
what are they do you see you see how much it's important to frame the level
you see how much it's important also to understand where to put break even try to guess it took us
at zero took us out at zero so we are still 3.5 r in profit why i put the break even point and zero
is point at 65 why guys what do you think
this is where the buyers got completely absorbed
this is where the buyers got completely absorbed okay so it's a level where you could expect to see
sellers getting back in the sellers getting back in let's see where we are in the frame we are
close to the rejection area of the value area low
dancing in the middle and when we are dancing in the middle i don't know if you remember
but we have this market scenario
but we can still make money as i told you we can still make money with it the important stuff is
that you are fast in putting your stop loss to break even so considering that we took break even on
this one i think we can continue we didn't reach the 2.5 r
i have to go thanks so much fabio have a nice evening john
if we go again of course we go again guys we are trading
choppy market and yeah we can make money i could have never think about it
it's thank you anas
i'm here till midnight guys don't exaggerate that maybe on thursday we find an amazing trend following
day we make 10 r in one day or 20 r like i did in the session in one day today it's a little bit boring
today it's a little bit boring yes this this is right red one said something really smart the
hardest condition is the best for us to learn and also when to stay out when to stay out and when
to cover yourself fast remember if you can close even one hour on the most boring and consolidation
days you will be a monster in the trend following days
pedro it's amazing is there anyone from japan almost three in the morning for me i have really
a lovely audience base
why do you not consider shots in the market condition because i'm really close to value area
low robin no where is who is the guy that says
damien i'm really close to the value area low so i can have this surge of aggressive sellers that brings
me back here but the risk to reward is not enough because where i need to put my risk
risk i need to put my risk above the last move it's not the best but yes i think the the sellers
are controlling the auction that's the reason i'm not touching anything now
i mean we could try look for shorts earlier of course of course damien
of course damien there is one logic that is the gap fill probability and the gap fill probability of the
gas cash session is closing with 75 percent so for me this was an amazing opportunity to get a scalp
that healed me a huge risk to reward as an intraday move but the market was not ready to do it today
but still we made money out of it this this move if this was not absorbed will be an amazing play
but still three are it's not bad no
now we are going really close to value area low no we are in value area low we are overlapping the
value area low of the previous and super close to the actual no short from here are a little bit
risky we have a cluster of the best
levels here that you can see one two three four these were the super aggression that we saw at the
beginning of the session we are getting close to them
let's see if the market can do something interesting there
we even consider pre-market high low areas as key levels to trade from
pre-market high low pre-market high low can be used also for orb and ibb model
yeah unfortunately yes there is no there is not the same probability and we are going through the
late new york session so i don't think we will have a volatility surge in the end
power hour the problem is that
is this the problem that we have two long two new york session overlapping cash
and we have really strong up level and down level and
i don't think we will change this behavior for today
i think we will continue to ping pong between this area this doesn't mean that you cannot make money
doesn't mean that you cannot make money just it's not the best condition my friends
i want to see this play i want to see this play here i want to see what sellers do when they engage back
this huge surge of aggression
overlapping with value area low that it's here of the cash
not best condition for sniper but still amazing condition to make money
this cell move was good this cell move was good like there is someone in the chat guys that after
this strong move after this strong move here capitalize on this collapse of momentum using the
big order it's really difficult to watch the chart and see every opportunity but this one was
possible to take it's looking like two stack profile and market yeah the the probabilities that we will
continue down yes but i don't think today
i'm in that short still holding till the aggression i love you guys good rick amazing
amazing the battlefield group is this the bottom the battlefield group is the best professional in the
group trading together i think it's an amazing idea i will create the chat to do this before thursday
and you can all confront each other together trade
some chart correction sometimes i can participate it will be amazing
is there any connection for this chop bank holiday from yesterday yesterday was bank holiday today the
volume is there the problem is regime like the market is building okay and we know that
below value area of the session and above value area of the session this is the scenario so
everything we do inside the area we are we know what we are in engaging great session of english
hey it's not finished it's not finished i want to see what they do here i want to see what they do here
i'm really curious we needed to take an additional trade we only took a break even so i have another shot
i want to see what they do here
you mean options dark
yeah we can we can see it we can see options if you like why not it's more advanced but we can see it
statistically there is only like 10 percent chance that we will break 25 225.
what statistical model are you using the
the maximum options exposure like the call wall and the put wall
ah initial balance breakout okay
initial balance breakout lulu they're going to the area squeeze
the guys the guys that took this momentum shorts i think it's time to take out your amazing one
two three you took an amazing trade this is momentum squeeze it's amazing
what platform are you using ud2 is this um how is it called options depth
oh this is not option stepped
gag stream i never tried it is it nice guys
look at this look at this level look at this amazing level let me see the speed of tape
uh
you already enter look at this he entered this absorption
on the way down i don't know if the color is visible but this anyway should be red
should be purple sorry guys you are super fast in entering yeah they are fighting we have a ceiling
and we have a bottom range the play here is the following
it's the following
maybe also this one one two three one two three
you mentioned in one of your lives there was some free resource so resources to see the options wall
to use as confluence yes you can use bar charts or option charts for put wall and call wall
be careful guys that is not accepting it's getting rejected
you see on this horizontal level this is not valid
these aggressive sell orders got completely completely rejected the buyers
this is not valid you need to wait for this breakout
so let's start defending yeah still defending
and dominating the speed of tape
now they are pushing now they are confirming the setup that i gave you but i need to close
every time they try they get absorbed it means that on this top range
there is a huge passive order wall
so is it okay to put on top of the candle yes why not why not but sometimes it sleep you i prefer to enter limit
prefer to enter limit maybe when i see the candle developing it depends on you guys you will like to see
more order from microstructure or you will also like to see swing macro model what you like more
scalp you see every everyone's scalp they love this session look at this amazing entry
i hear you smoking
look they are already inside from the bottom i love you peter we cooking they are guys they don't have
time to lose the community of blood sweat and scalp don't have time to lose already they are floating
5 000 then we talk about the re-entry what what an amazing you see this is the the benefit of doing
advanced professional only community i'm a beginner i love you watch the free content but don't enter here
we're in because we already understand the concept of course ina more than happy for you it's unfolding
amazingly this is a one two three till this level
the break-even point is this level here that is the last point of aggression
that is mid between the final target and the other one the invalidation point is this let's go to poc and
close this amazing session let's see if it goes otherwise we close at 2.5 2.5 r
we are up on this setup do we aim for the last high no it's to you are late in the session to aim for the
the value area you have not a huge probability of reaching it i will prefer a quick scalper one two
three closing 6.5 r and we close an amazing session what a beautiful test guys what a beautiful test if
it creates if it prints an aggression candle really strong an aggression candle really strong you can
also think to go risk free immediately this is the good about order flow you don't need always to wait
if you have a confirmation to go risk free
no it's not impossible it's possible that it goes back to value rei
right on point look look how they scalp guys everyone making money
i'm out for today looking hold my profit of course hold your profit
it's not via templates you just add the speed of tape it's super easy
i want to see if the buyers get aggressive on this movement up they push this level because this
means that you can put immediately your stop to risk free here and also this position it's offered
by the market
the sellers are defending at this level look at look at this week
lulu look lulu look lulu look these buyers
there is a huge battle inside here let me activate the speed what's happening here
what are you doing
fighters
fabio why do you think today's session before opening of live made 90 of my profit there it was amazing
before session but usually it's better new york now we took a consolidation session but what best way
to start with the world session of the week in terms of condition and making profit also on this
isn't it better if the session that we do together are all explosion long with 20r what would you learn
it's better guy trust me it's better that we have a super bad session not in profit but in condition
you have time by yourself to get an amazing explosion but reading with me together how i deal with
garbage session is the best value you can get is the best value you can get and during these months we
will have a lot of bad session a lot of consolidating not moving you go break even you go risk free
you go break even you don't want to know anything from this market anymore you are already risk free
i tell you my two chance i will take one to one risk to reward close at 5.5 r if you want to shoot for the one
to uh one to 1.8 it was or one two three final you can close at 6.5 r
but the session is done take your risk out we fight
my take guys is a quick scalp closing at 4.5 r i will not hold i will not hold till here but this is the
profit target of the potential of the trade let's see how it goes my position will have been taken out here
it's really difficult biba i it's already difficult to read the chat and chart if i need
also to manage the position you know the account that i work with it's it's really big
in trend following it's more easy i think we will make some session where i open trend following
trades i hold and i just need to monitor the stopping profit but when it's so choppy you see
how much you need to be fast you amazing teacher thank you ricky you have an important second name
you have an important second name ricky
general the elastic band couldn't color we go now
but let's see if the decision of uh of the general of taking out the position it's a smart decision
i don't like the behavior of the market guys today i don't like i can see already when it's
min reverting completely so
worst case scenario you go break even so not bad at all still 3.5 r
once i saw your first video with reads i dream to become but you know why i open this service you
know why i open this service guys because i receive a feedback i will not make names and i will not tell you
which of which mentor i receive a feedback from a 24 years old wealthy wealthy individual he came to
me and say fabi it's impossible that is not possible your life paying you there are people that wants to
pay you and you have to consider that there are people that pretend to trade that that charge
5 000 for a garbage course make something not too high ticket affordable for people that are really
interested and give them the possibility to access live in the market with you without a pre-recorded
course only for professionals that's what i did this for one thousand dollars we basically scammed you
thank you guys
so so you have to thank thomas the guy was it's called thomas
guys today we did two hours and a half of session two hours and a half of session rest a little bit
milk the money and be ready so if you kept the position not yet to break even but it's going to
break even so the decision of taking it out at one r was really nice we close at 4.5 r for the day
super choppy session super amazing management of the risk and the position and the profit uh on the
build position i hope you enjoyed the session i hope you are happy with this service
it depends on you if we do also the q2 so if you want to continue on these two months it depends on
how you feel with the session i created with you a section that is called testimonials
in the blood sweat and scalps let me know what do you think take 30 seconds after i gave you two
hours and a half to write what do you think about the service i see you next thursday i hope we will
see a trend following day and we will milk the market even more 4.5 r we close the session amazing
session explanation on the first two models we continue also the explanation practical i will
make sure to make a file for you where you can find all my supplements to manage the stress that we go
through as traders and i will also continue to train the chatbot have an amazing day guys see you soon
so
you